a really nice theme of trying to make
random Quantum circuit experiments more
verifiable by adding structure to the
experiment so Dominican glider here from
the University of Maryland uh we'll tell
us more
awesome
thanks very much bill for inviting me to
give the talk here I'm really excited to
be telling you all about this research
which I've been doing together with
Michael gullins also at Maryland and
it's really following the theme that
Scott introduced this morning and
actually already introduced last year at
this same conference and those of you
who are here will remember it's the
question whether there's a Quantum
Advantage which is scalable verifiable
and nisky
okay and I'm going to talk about the
same set of experiments namely this
random circuit samplings as I call them
Quantum random sampling and experiments
and I'm going to ask the question
whether we can make them somewhat more
verifiable
I'm not going to claim that in the end
there will be a fully verified Quantum
Advantage but maybe we can you know do
little steps towards that goal
okay and before I you know dive into the
talk I want to already give you the
highlights and the sort of uh tell you
what what you're going to be expecting
so I'll introduce a new scheme a new
setting
um of quantum random sampling in which
instead of doing Quantum random sampling
on a single copy of a Quantum system
we're now going to copy that that random
circuit on a on a second copy and then
we're going to do a bell measurement
that's basically the setting and what
I'm hoping to show you today is that in
this setting we have hardness of
sampling very similar as in random
circuit sampling we also have structured
distributions on which we can do
property tests some of which are
efficient some of which are inefficient
if you're a physicist if I'm here I'm a
physicist if you're a physicist you can
do efficient Fidelity estimation in the
same setting in which cross entropy
benchmarking Works in these circuits
if you're a computer scientist well I
have a couple of proposals for you and
these are by by no means complete and
fully thought through and but there are
proposals that I invite all of you to
think about and that I think would be
really exciting to make some progress on
so the first is the Quantum Advantage
test that maybe is a little bit more
difficult to spoof than just cross
entropy benchmarking
and the second is the suggestion that
maybe Bell sampling might actually be
more noise robust in a scalable sense
than random circuits
So the plan for the talk is to do a
brief recap of quantum random sampling
then I'll introduce the Bell sampling
protocol and I'll talk about noisy Bell
sampling
I'll briefly talk about Bell sampling in
experiments
and the question of scalability and then
give you an Outlook and some open
question
and throughout this talk I will invite
you to have you know raise questions
um and I will myself raise more
questions than I have answers are you
making actually sure that the final
state that you're measuring is about
you're just sort of you're just testing
that Elizabeth stayed out of a random
let's get to that in a moment okay I'll
go into more detail
um
right okay
good so let's start with a brief recap
of quantum random sampling in the noise
okay the noiseless case what we have is
we have a Quantum random you a random
Quantum circuit which we draw you know
classically from some family say we draw
individual random Gates we put them on
some architecture and then the task is
to sample from the output distribution
which is just this computational basis
output distribution
okay for example I will go through this
reasonably quickly and we have the
circuits which are chosen in the Google
experiment where there's some fixed two
to two qubit gates depending on the
architecture you know and the staggered
pattern that Scott was explaining and
then there's certain random single qubit
dates and then you repeat this layer by
layer and in the end you sample from the
output distribution
okay for these types of circuits we have
essentially two tasks that we well we
have the sampling tasks that we can we
can consider
um and we have two sorts of hardness
arguments
um for the sampling task the first
hardness argument is to due to a Bremner
Joe's a shepherd and Scott Aronson Alex
archipov
um which which basically is that
assuming some complexity theoretic
conjectures related to um the output
distribution the simulability of the
output distribution and then the famous
polynomial hierarchy collapse there is
no efficient classical algorithm that's
approximately samples from that
distribution within a constant total
variation
the second type of task that you can
consider is just you know instead of
sampling you can just consider the task
of producing a couple of outcomes which
have an average probability with respect
to the ideal circuit which is larger
than two to then that's essentially this
cross entropy benchmarking test
okay
so let's take a look at the distribution
the distribution in Quantum random
sampling is very unstructured is very
close to the uniform distribution if you
just look at the individual probability
all of them are roughly on the same
order of magnitude as the uniform
distribution which is this red dotted
line here
if you draw the probabilities in a
histogram you see this exponential decay
so most of the probabilities are on the
order of the uniform distribution or
even smaller than that
okay let me now briefly talk about
verifiability of quantum random
subject well the first observation that
you can make is that if you want to
actually verify total variation distance
this very stringent task that we were
setting in the in the complexity
argument then this is something that
will require exponentially samples
exponentially many samples and the
reason for that is very simple the
largest probability is just
exponentially small and so to resolve
that I will just need exponentially
so now we can look at weaker tasks such
as cross entropy benchmarking
as I said before which in this x yes
isn't the largest probability even
smaller than that with more like n over
2 to the end yeah this is like the
regular response that we can prove
but if you have exponentially
distributed yeah probability
right then the other task that we can
consider is this course entropy
benchmarking plus here we just get
samples from the distribution we
calculate the average ideal probability
corresponding to those samples
if your your circuit U here is you
sufficiently random anti-concentrates or
forms of two designers so then we have
exactly this property that Scott was
already already telling you that if you
have the ideal circuit the cross entropy
Benchmark is one if you have a uniformly
random uniformly random samples then the
cross entry benchmark Financial
good
so there are two nice things about this
cross entropy Benchmark the first is
it's sample efficient you can
efficiently
um estimate it from a small number of
experimental samples so you don't
actually need to run your Quantum device
for months you can just run it for a few
hours or so
the second is that here the cross
entropy Benchmark actually gives us a
distinguish against the uniform
distribution
that's essentially what this property is
telling you right for the for the ideal
distribution you have a high score for
the uniform distribution
you can also look at it from a
complexity perspective and make the
claim that it's hard to achieve a higher
score on this benchmark classically
that's basically what the Google
experiment is based on like the
supremacy is claimed is based on this uh
on this complexity theoretic effect
okay now if we look at efficient tests
computationally and Sample efficient
tests then we actually believe that we
can't even efficiently distinguish
samples from a random circuit from the
uniform distribution
and then what I'm going to talk about
um this property will be relaxed and we
will actually be able to distinguish the
samples from Bell sampling from the
uniform distribution
any questions so far
oh great
awesome yeah property was that last
that's I wouldn't say it's a proven
result it's more a belief that we have
yeah I guess it's basically
um yeah that's all I want to say we
really believe that we can't efficiently
distinguish samples from the from random
circuit samples from
and that belief breaks down in the
sampling that's when you're for example
we can probably distinguish it
efficiently from you
good
okay let's talk about Bell something
about sampling instead of taking a
single copy now we will take two copies
take the same random circuit we take two
copies and we perform a bell measurement
the task is to sample from the output
distribution
so let's lose a couple of words on the
output distribution
so the output distribution I can write
as follows we have C tensor C applied to
some fiducial initial State and then we
compute the overlap with the Bell State
the Bell State so the output string is
now a 2N bit string
okay the Bell State I just write as the
zero zero plus one one Bell State and
apply a powerly on one of the on one of
the systems
and I will label the police with the
zero zero zero one one zero one one
simplexic representation right so the
one one probably that's going to be
important later is the Y poly that
corresponds to the singlet set the zero
zero one zero and zero one paulies are z
x and all that
that's the Bell sampling distribution
the first point I want to make Bell
sampling is actually realistic in
near-term experiments even I would say
in today's experiments in particular in
two architectures that there may be more
one is rootberg atoms and Optical
tweezers so let's say okay what what
makes those sampling difficult in
near-term experiments it's of course the
Bell measurement between the two systems
right so if you have a local
architecture then you need to do many
swaps in order to do
but in some architectures in which you
have long range
interactions such a goodberg atoms or
iron traps you can just do the spell
measurement in a single layer of a
circuit
yes that's good it's still nisky
the second property I want to briefly go
through is that Bell sampling is still
hard we can still run the same hardness
argument that we can run for single copy
bear sample for single copy random
circuit sampling for Bell sampling okay
let me briefly run you through the
properties that we need to check the
first property is hiding that that comes
off the Bell sample um of the Bell
sampling
um are interchangeable with the
distribution of random circuits it's a
little bit tricky here because now we
have two systems we have this Paulie in
between but it turns out that if the
um the distribution of a random circuits
is invariant over roots of the of
polygates at the end then we have this
hiding property
the second thing we should check is
approximate average case hardness of
concluding the probability in particular
well we can't prove it but we have
evidence for it we can look at worst
case approximate hardness average case
near exact hardness and
anti-concentration
worst case approximate hardness holds as
we show because we can embed the gap of
an arbitrary Boolean function using
Universal Quantum circuits
average case near exact hardness just
holds by standard arguments that we have
by now for any continuous gate set
and then anti-concentration is a little
bit more tricky because now we have two
copies turns out we need fourth moments
and so it holds if you have a unitary
four design
by result of hero and miraban we get
unitary four designs in depth which
scales us n to the one over the
dimension of the system
um and so we also have examples for
random service which anti-concentrate in
Bell sampling
can you say again what is the benefit
for of doing bowel sampling as opposed
to just measuring in the computational
basis that's coming into mind
no no I I haven't gotten there yet
um good the first question here I have
is well for single copy random circuits
we know that they anti-concentrate
already in logarithmic depth
it's not clear if this is the case for
Bell sampling but you know it's a very
reasonable thing to believe that fourth
moments or maybe even all moments I
think Michael has
something that even all moments
anti-concentrate
um
in logarithmic depth even
okay
so now let's come to the benefits of
bell sampling
which is that the distribution has
structure
so in a sense this is precisely
answering well a little part of the
question that's got raised in his
previous talk okay let's look at the
Bell sampling distribution what
structure do we have
and I will explain this in detail in a
moment the first structure that we have
is is that it's supported on what I call
the symmetric Subspace
and I will tell you in a moment what
that means the second is that the
outcomes have some correlations and we
will also see what exact what exact
correlations they will have the third is
that the support of the Bell sampling
distribution is pretty large
actually full and yeah and and that
corresponds to what we call the
stabilizer dimension
and the fourth is that it's still
anti-concentrated on the symmetric
substrate so it still satisfies this
anti-concentration property which is
then relevant for cross-entropy
benchmarking
related questions
okay so if you go back to our picture
before we still have a
detox looks a little bit like the random
circuit sampling distribution except
that for some outcomes so say the
outcomes in the anti-symmetric Subspace
we now know that the amplitudes are zero
great okay so let's go through these
properties one by one and in in the
process of doing that we will also see
how we get efficient and some
inefficient tests for the properties
[Music]
First Property the support the support
on the symmetric Subspace
so to explain why that holds I'll need
the swap operator so the two qubit swap
operator I can express in the Bell basis
as just the sum of the projectors with
um Paulie zero zero one zero zero one
minus the the singlet projector because
that's the unique
um anti-symmetric state for two qubits
okay
then the global swap operator is just
the product of all local operators
okay what can we do with that we can do
a swap test great
so if we want to compute the purity of a
Quantum State we can just Express this
in terms of the swap operator on two
copies of that Quantum State and that's
exactly what we're going to do
and what we what we see here is that
this swap operator we can express in the
Bell basis as just as the sum overall
outcomes and then minus one of the
outcomes in the anti-symmetric Subspace
with an odd number of one one outcomes I
call this that the Y parody of the
outcome
and plus one if the outcome is in the
symmetric clusters
okay good so in particular if we have a
pure State we know that the Purity is
one great so for any state actually not
not just random circuits for any state
and the bell samples will be supported
on the symmetric surface
awesome
and I already gave you an efficient test
right because here we just sample from
the Bell from the Bell distribution if
we just sample from the Bell
distribution we compute the Y parody of
the outcomes and we average them we'll
just get an estimate of the purity of
the quantum state
okay in particular if you have a pure
Quantum State and if you see an
anti-symmetric outcome you already know
um
that the state was not pure
okay
are you happy with this questions
okay okay let's go to the next next
property namely correlations
is about the classical samples or if you
had the quantum stated measure this is
about the classical samples okay right
so this is about a property of the ideal
Quantum just of the ideal output just
are we going to get to noisy Bell
samples
is that a typo because you're it should
be S2 in that equation
No it should be the global
what is that exactly I have a state on N
Cube row is a state on n qubits and I
express now the the big s in terms of
the little S's and then I get this
product
that makes sense thank you
and sorry and suppose that all four
properties that you listed you know hold
is your argument going to be that that
helps with verifiability in some way
yeah
I mean the first sort of verifiability
where they see here right so swap test
gives us verification of at least this
property the support property
okay now we can do that swap test on
subsystems because the swap operator is
just a product of the local swap
operators we can just do it on
subsystems as well right so if I now
just look at the substrings I can
compute an estimate of the subsystem
Purity so I take some subsystem of my
qubits and I take the substring of the
outcomes that I get from Bell sampling
um I can compute an estimate of the
subsystem purity
but we know something about the
entanglement structure of quantum States
in particular we know that the maximal
entanglement we can in principle get is
this triangle here right it's just the
maximally mixed state on
um
on the subsystem which is just given by
the dimension of the subsystem the the
we need to entanglement entropy
okay but now if I have restricted
circuits say circuits which are
restricted in depth at some point the
entanglement entropy is not going to be
dominated by the size of the subsystem
anymore but just the depth of the
circuit right because with low depth
circuit I can generate only so much
entanglement
so this gives me a test which
distinguishes circuits with low depth
from say circuits with high depth
if I want to make it a little bit more
fine-grained rather than just comparing
maximal entanglement against what I see
the in the experiment I can also look at
average entanglement properties
in particular we can compute average
entanglement properties for certain
ensembles of State famously they're
called page curves
um page already in the 90s computed that
for high random States and it's
something that looks you know it lies
underneath here it's a little bit curved
there's a little correction here
um at half cuts
[Music]
what I'm testing for the subsystem is
the purity of the subsystems
okay the purity of a subsystem is a
measure of entanglement of the quantum
state
um so if I have a random circuit I can
compute well we don't have it yet this
is going to be one of the questions I
can hopefully compute entanglement
properties of random Quantum States on
subsystems of a certain size
and then compare
are you
are you hoping or saying that this is
so the logarithm of the pure
I'm hoping that we can compute that with
say statistical mechanics models
okay but even in the absence of a like
of an exact expression for the average
entanglement if we can estimate this
precisely we can still distinguish the
case like different faces here right if
we see an entanglement that's pretty
large up here then we know like an
entanglement entropy that's pretty large
then we know that the circuit must be
must have a certain depth for it
but
okay so this also gives me an efficient
test which I call subsystem swab test
okay and about efficiency we will have
to talk because the values and that I
actually get will be exponentially small
in the size of the subsystem or
um the depth of the circuit so here
there's a question of sample efficiency
coming out but at least if I look at
small size subsystems or very large size
subsystems the value of the entanglement
is not exponentially small in the
systems
and so I can efficiently estimate that
or distinguish at least from very small
values
I mean sample efficiently and okay
computational efficient efficiency is
not a problem here because just what I'm
doing is I'm Computing the Y parity of
the
um
of the substring corresponding to the
substance so here's really a question of
sample efficiency
but
okay so here's the question what is
actually this what do these average
entanglement properties actually look
like for interesting circuit
Orthodontics say restricted depth are
random to local unitaries what what are
the what do what do the average
entanglement properties like that
let me continue with my next property
and test which I call stabilizer
Dimension and you'll see in a moment why
that's the case and the related magic
test
okay so this this test is based on the
observation that I can just rewrite the
output probably the expression for the
output probabilities in terms of an
overlap with my state and the complex
conjugate of the state with the poly
Matrix corresponding to an outcome
okay
then we know that if we have a
stabilizer state so if C is a Clifford
circuit
then the distribution PC of R is
actually supported essentially up to a
shift on the stabilizer of s and when I
what do I mean by the stabilizer of s i
mean the outcome strings corresponding
to power lease in the stabilizer of s
okay so we have an exponentially small
support right the stabilizer of s is 2
to the n large the outcome space is 4 to
the n large so we have exponentially
small support for stabilizer States
but so now what if I add T gates to my
circuit well the support increases of
course until I get maximal support on
the symmetric Subspace in particular I
can write this c c bar Operator just as
a sum
from some subgroup of the polygirl over
some over polish from some subgroup of
the polygroup
Sigma L times the projector onto another
subgroup of the Pauli group
and some shift which is related to the
complex conjugate
okay so the dimension of this L subgroup
here tells me something about the Magic
in my Quantum state in particular I
think William called this the stabilizer
dimension in the recent paper
um the dimension of this is bounded I
think by 2T
I don't want to lie about the factor of
two I think it's 2T
great so this is a measure of magic
so we can distinguish states which are
stabilizer States from states which have
a large number of key Gates
in fact we can even learn a Clifford
plus T circuit with TT gates from n log
n Mini Bell samples
and then order 2 to the T many
additional measurements on some other
Quantum state
okay and this also gives us a magic text
which is efficient because we can just
estimate it from order n log n menu Bell
samples what you do is you just take
differences between the Bell samples to
eliminate this K dependency are
essentially
and then you look at the dimension of
the subgroup generator generated by
those sequences
okay so that tells us essentially that
the Bell distribution if you have a
large number of T Gates has a reasonably
large support in the symmetric substance
the question is though well I gave you
an upper bound but maybe it's actually
true that the dimension is roughly the
same as 2T 2T for random circuits
I don't know I don't have a good
intuition but that might be the case
yes
so
um first of all if I ignore the
structure of your circuit and I just
look at the state and I want to test
whether to stabilize the state or or a
different state yes
um that requires a lot of heat are you
saying that there is a measurement
that distinguishes that was known before
what we did
so the measurement the measurement is
just about measurement so here I'm just
if it's I don't have I don't have a
division to two parts so how do I do
that
suppose I just give you a statement
to measure whether it's a stabilizer
state or or a state that requires a lot
of tea from a single copy I mean I'm
giving you many copies but I don't give
you you give you a single copy you
measure then I give you another copy you
cannot understand if I can't entangle
them I'm not sure
experts correct results
okay yeah so you really need
I think
okay so let's recap again so we looked
at three properties of the love
distribution support on the symmetric
Subspace large stabilizer Dimension and
correlations in the outcome
corresponding to the entanglement
properties of the underlying
compensation
I also gave you computationally
efficient in the subsystem swap test
maybe sample inefficient tests for these
properties that's right the test that
you just talked about wouldn't that only
be non-trivial for like random circuits
that are mostly stabilizer and that have
just a small number of t-gates it's just
a sanity check all right
okay and then we will probably still
need the xcb test later what that tests
is basically that the distribution has
the right heavy outcomes that's an
inefficient test but that will still
work because of the anti-concentration
properties
of circles
okay
immediately these tests give us state
distinguishes
right in particular the global swap
tests distinguish against the global
uniform distribution right because you
know the globally uniform distribution
will have odd wide parity outcomes the
magic test will distinguish from output
distributions which are generated by
stable by Clifford circuits or our
circuits with a few with a small number
of keys
is it correct I would imagine that
if if instead you had two classes I did
you know you were sampling from two
identical clusters yes
and then you did uh you know Corey uh
you know yeah
that would not give this right it has to
do it has it really has to do and it is
exactly it's really the reduced density
Matrix that you need for example for the
subsystem swap tests or the magic test
even the global swap test
because we don't have the support
constraint if you just have same
Les right single copy samples would just
be supported on the entire
roughly
sorry what they were saying was that you
know if you're comparing between these
two noisy random circuits versus uh to
classical
or you know yes
uh you know similar
you know that light just there it would
it would act very different I think so
yes yeah yeah I think so yeah I mean if
you had I mean of course if you just had
a reversible classical circuit that will
still give you a small one right but if
you have probabilities in there
oh like this image of the guest is
mostly like specific types of Contour
because you're not claiming anything
about classical circuits yet I'm at the
moment I'm just I'm not claiming
anything about classical algorithms okay
I'm just claiming something about
classical distributions right so
classical distributions which are
generated by Quantum circuits with
uniform say on the symmetric Subspace
good
okay like one question that you can ask
here is how actually does the test score
on one of those tests translate in the
total variation distance lower bounds
between the two between the two
distributions
questions about this
oh great then let me get to noisy about
something
and this is where it's going to get
interesting and where
um I hope you apologize that I proceed
hermeneutically I'm not going to give
you an answer I'm going to give you a
lot of questions and I'm going to sort
of hopefully
um introduce you to the subtleties of
this
and so to start out let's briefly recap
what happens in the single copy Quantum
random sample case in noisy
so here we're facing our tricky thing
right right we have on the one on the
one hand a noisy Quantum device
that noisy Quantum device that's
exponentially decaying fidelity
on the other hand we have some classical
algorithm which has exponential
computational costs so we have two
exponentials which are somehow fighting
each other and this is where everything
becomes really subtle and tricky as
we've already heard in the discussions
of the previous
let's look at for example the cross
entropy benchmarks
and what does the quantum device do on
that score
in the regime of low local noise for
this the one over n noise regime
we know that the noisy Quantum device
xcp score scales exponentially in the
size of the circuit which essentially is
now going to be exponentially in the
depth of the circuit right because we
scale the noise as one over n
in that regime we also know that the xcb
score relates to the Fidelity of the
underlying Quantum state
that's something that abena will talk I
think more about later this afternoon
on the other side we have classical
algorithms there we know actually an
efficient classical spoofer
um in this you know in the same regime
somehow in the sense that
um shungao and others a couple of years
ago gave an algorithm which achieves a
score which scales also exponentially in
the in the depth on The cross-entropy
Benchmark so here the situation becomes
really intricate right you have two
exponential decays which are somehow the
same and now you're trying to compare
them
that's noisy that's all I'm going to say
for the moment about noisy Quantum
random sampling
let's see what happens in the Bell
sampling
so how well can a noisy Quantum device
or on the other hand an efficient
classical algorithm do on those tests
that I was presenting to you
okay noisy belt sampling
well the first thing to note is that is
that the cross entropy Benchmark in some
sense has similar properties right we
still have anti-concentration
um and so we we expect that the the
properties of the Cross entropy
Benchmark will will be the same right if
you have certain types of noise on your
Quantum State the Decay will be very
similar in the cross entropy Benchmark
how exactly I don't know
this is something to be explored how
exactly does the cross entropy Benchmark
decay in different noise regimes with
different noise models
now let's consider the swap test this is
where things become interesting and now
let's starting start to Make Some Noise
assumptions
right we need to start modeling our
device to say anything about what the
noisy Quantum device can do the noise
assumptions that I want to make is
um the White Noise approximation what we
call the White Noise approximation which
is basically that the noisy Quantum
state is just a linear combination of
the ideal Quantum State and the
maximally mixed state
okay this is basically an assumption
that was used in the Google experiment
and that we have some evidence for that
it holds in this regime of low noise
here's the noise right so when I have a
circuit which has local noise after each
two qubit gate with strength Epsilon if
that Epsilon is smaller than one over n
roughly then I think we believe that the
um that the white noise approximation
should fall
the other assumption that I want to make
for the moment is that the measurement
is actually ideal so that we don't have
any noise in the measurement
good
so what happens okay remember our page
curves the how the entanglement behaves
as a
um as a function of the subsystem size
now we have two states right we have the
ideal pure State and then we have the
maximally mixed state on the other hand
if we look at how the swap test behaves
for the American limits that you can see
this large discrepancy right the
maximally mixed state subsystem Purity
just goes up straight up to one over two
to the N right because any subsystem
that I take of the maximum mix state
will be maximally mixed
so here I actually have a way of
distinguishing these two cases the these
two cases in which in which I can be
right in particular if I look at the
Purity the maximally mixed state at very
large subsystems will have
um will have very large
entropy very small Purity sorry
okay if I have a noise strength of ETA
that just means that the the Purity
um decays linearly in ETA essentially
okay and then I can play the game for
smaller size subsystem as well and I
will see that the Purity again decays
somehow in ETA
I don't know very much about what the
magic test is going to do in the
presence of noise because of course
that's also going to be very very
sensitive to this type of noise right
because I increase the support on the
entire uh on the entire space so the
magic test if I just run it naively
um will just give me you know a large
number for the magic even though I
actually have a maximum
yes to go back to the question you asked
earlier yes I just I'm not sure whether
an answer to this as well good question
okay so for the same
um
we don't know if a TVD lower bound
okay computer security and we don't know
we don't know exactly we don't know
exactly that was the question yes you
asked that okay so okay
but if we do assume that there's like
white noise then we grow up again
yes
is that is that hey
yeah
so intuitively in terms of the
resilience of the magic test uh you
would expect and I'm really throwing uh
yeah but you would expect the behavior
that's similar to what the swap does
is
[Music]
okay
good
so now okay that's all I wanted to say
about what the what the values of the of
the various hats are going to be in the
presence of noise but there's another
interesting thing to be noted about Bell
sampling in the presence of noise namely
that we can also use that structure to
detect errors and in that sense Bell
sampling I think think of it as a nice
intermediate scheme between the single
copy case and the fully fault tolerant
case where we can detect all errors
hopefully
in the Bell sampling we can detect some
errors right so in particular if we see
an outcome
um which is uh which has an
anti-symmetric
um y parity then we know that it can't
come from the correct distribution and
we can say well this outcome has that an
error has to have happened in order for
this outcome to be produced
and we can say play the same game
um for La for large size subsystems
right if I take
um the sub like an outcome and I look at
all subsystems of size n minus one in
the white noise approximation
um I know that every error is equally
likely
so if I look at all subsystems of uh of
an outcome string then I know roughly
what sort of fraction of odd y parity
outcomes I should expect
and I can use that to detect errors
probabilistically probably
and I can play that game for large
constant sized subsystems
well n minus constant size subsistence
and in each in each step I'm going to
get some sort of error reduction right
roughly on the anti-symmetric test I'm
going to get on a factor of two or so on
the errors and so on with with you know
decreasing size subsystems
the question is what actually is going
to be the error suppression if I do if I
continue this for a constant number
and computed
well then of course the other question
is what happens if I have different
noise models right in this in these
arguments I presumed
um white noise that all errors are
equally likely and nice that the
measurement is ideal of course this is
maybe not a very realistic
um setting in in actual experiments
so the question is what happens to these
error detection properties if you have
um errors that behave a little bit
differently or even if you have errors
on the measurement which is of course
the the ultimate question here in the
belt sampling case what happens if you
have errors on the mission
okay
now let's look at classical algorithms
what do we know about classical
algorithms well okay we already said for
the magic test uniform samples will give
me a high score so here I can just
sample uniformly and get a high score so
this is not going to be a test that's
going to be hard to spoof for a
classical algorithm
for the subsystem swap test the
situation becomes a little bit more
intricate right on the one hand Clifford
circuits generate very high entanglement
on the other hand maybe if I can compute
the exact average entanglement
properties then I can still be I might
still be able to distinguish my circuit
or sample from random clipboard circuits
the big question I think to me is
whether the spoofing algorithm by GAO
and others will still work
right so the spoofing algorithm there
the idea was well you have a noisy
circuit
that essentially deletes some edges in
my tensor Network so why don't I just
judiciously select certain edges in the
tensor Network and so that my simulation
becomes easier
and then simulate and you know hopefully
get a high score on the cross entropy
matchback turns out they got a
reasonably high score right and a score
which only decays exponentially in the
depth
well this cut here can be detected by
our swap test right if I know where Uhn
cut his sensor Network then I will be
able to run my swap test on exactly that
partition of the circuit and realize
well there was a pure State here
so from the samples option I can
actually tell him well no no you
actually ran this circuit and by
partition and it was pure along this cut
now if you look at an adversarial
scenario where Sean doesn't tell me
where he actually made the cut then
Things become more complicated right
because then I might have to maximize
over large size subsystems and this
maximization will become difficult
um yeah so one one idea for a test could
be you just maximize the purity of a
large size subsystems or half cuts and
another idea is you can compare the
Purity to the average Purity it's not
really set in stone what exactly a good
test that would distinguish samples
against an adversarial spoofing
algorithm could be
okay
on the other hand we also know that the
classical algorithm can also use the
error correction right that's of course
an exponential cost for the classical
algorithm but they can in principle pay
that cost and you know produce samples
which are compatible with my tests
the question is
um how does that sort of error
correction actually fair if my samples
didn't come from say a mixture between
the ideal distribution and the uniform
distribution but a distribution which
was generated Say by a circuit like this
which you know maybe has something to do
with the ideal distribution but not
really maybe in the one case the error
detection works much better than in the
other case because the sort of errors
that I see Will might be very different
in type
foreign
then the other question you can ask well
okay now we've added a lot of structure
to the distribution thus scoring a
higher score uh on the cross entropy
Benchmark maybe become easier because of
that maybe there's you know maybe it's
just there's a trivial way uh to score
um a score a score on the cross entropy
Benchmark which is bounded away from
zero now because I have the structure
maybe just sampling from you know random
Clifford circuits would already score
reasonably High because the correlations
in the distribution are
I like to compare this to the situation
in boson sampling in boson sampling
um we have this efficient state
distinguishers in particular we have
state distinguishers from the uniform
distribution or from distinguishable
bosons
but we don't really have a notion of a
cross-entropy benchmark because one we
don't know what the ideal score is and
two we don't know what actually the hard
score is right because even if I just
produce samples from the unifar
distribution in boson sampling I will
you know have a rough idea of the size
of the probabilities
distinguishable boson distribution I
will already get roughly an idea of you
know
I mean I mean are are there really two
separate problems here I mean I just
thought of it as one problem we don't
know what is the Benchmark that once you
exceed it then you're doing something
classically yeah yeah I think I'm okay
it's a question yes I like to divide the
problem into the statistical problem
right whether the question is you know
what's the ideal skull what's the fully
noisy and then the computational problem
which is you know how how high can you
actually score with
okay
so here's a proposed Quantum Advantage
test well we'll still probably need the
cross-entropy Benchmark because as I
told you the the test that I propose
individually will be spoofable
relatively easily but maybe in
conjunction with the cross entropy
Benchmark
um there's going to be a well I call it
proposition
um a hardness conjecture that
simultaneously achieving a good score on
all of those tests is maybe harder than
individually on the cross entropy
Benchmark because at least say the GAO
algorithm we can detect with the swap
test symptoms
and there's a varying scale of
efficiency versus inefficiency on those
tests
okay but then you can also ask the
question well do the new tests actually
add to xcb well maybe everything that I
um was able to see with xcb I can or um
um I can still see in the new test just
with xcb maybe the swap tests don't
actually happen I don't think that's
very likely because intuitively they
test for very different properties right
xcb test for heaviness of the outcomes
magic test test for flatness of the
distribution the entanglement test for
the structure of the
um of the correlations in my
in my in my distribution
well then the other you know
um when we say great
um is of course what's a good score
um on these tests say the magic test
what is a score that we you know in
conjunction with xcb would think is
classically intractable and there's
going to be a compromise that we saw
already for the subsystem swap test
right where maybe I have to optimize
over different subsystems in terms of
efficiency and classical interactability
all right
Impressions on this
okay but even if you you know don't
believe all of this I think Bell
sampling has a virtue namely on ice and
in front of my slides has a verb to
namely if you're an experiment
experimentalist you might be very
willing to believe those noise
conjectures right you might be very
willing I think the Google people are
very willing to believe the White Noise
conjecture you might be really very
willing to say that your measurements
well maybe they're not perfect but
they're nearly perfect
and then in that case
um you actually get an advantage because
we know that cross-entropy benchmarking
is an estimator of the quantum Fidelity
that's actually one of the main uses for
people in physics to use cross entropy
benchmarking you know why it spread a
little bit also beyond the random
circuit sampling Community it's actually
a way to measure the many body Fidelity
in systems which are what they call
chaotic
but it's an inefficient estimator with
bell sampling we have an efficient asset
okay and I've been up we'll talk about
this
um with Bella sampling we have an
efficient estimator because the Purity
in the presence of those noise
assumption give us an efficient
estimator of Fidelity in the white noise
regime right how do I see that well if
you have some noise parameter here and
the white noise
um approximation then both the Purity
and the um and the Fidelity of my
Quantum State I can just Express in
terms of in terms of that parameter and
so I can estimate the parameter from the
Purity and then estimate the Fidelity
from that
and then of course the same holds for
the entanglement properties
okay let me say a little bit about the
question of scalability or what you
might call the constant noise regime
sorry trying to simplify what you what
you just said you're saying that under
the assumption of measurements there's
no noise in the measurement and what was
the other assumption the other
assumption was this white noise
assumption or low noise or something
let's assume these two assumptions
you're saying that this this is a test
of advantage that that would be
efficiently verifiable
that's what you're saying no I'm just
saying that this is a test of this is a
way that I can actually measure the
physical Fidelity of the quantum state
so before okay let's go back to the side
before
okay
but yeah I was talking about an
advantage test right here I was talking
about you know we have these various
tests maybe scoring a higher score on
those tests actually is something that's
classically attractive
now I went away from being a computer
scientist to being a physicist and asked
well you know you have all of your data
it was sort of no
how the device is going to behave what
errors it's going to have I just want to
understand how well I did in terms of
preparing my Quantum state
then the Bell sampling gives you an
advantage over across entropy
benchmarking because the Purity is an
efficient computationally efficient
estimator of the Fidelity as opposed to
the cross-section
awesome
scalability
here the question that among others
dorit has addressed starting with Brenda
montanaro Shepard in 2017 and then
shungao and Juan
um is okay now let's say this constant
noise right I'm scaling up my system I'm
assuming there's constant local noise
after every gate thing
how hard is it to simulate the quantum
circuit well of course if you wait for
long enough if my run might circuit deep
enough everything is going to be uniform
and you know nothing interesting is
happening what's happening in the regime
in which the depth is not very large can
I come up with an algorithm which you
know the distribution approaches uniform
but it's not quite uniform yet can I
have come up with an algorithm which
will which will be polynomial time
um in the inverse noise and the number
of qubit synthesis
and then yes there is
there is a few assume anti-concentration
of the output distribution okay constant
depolarizing and local noise after every
gate you can come up with an efficient
classical Hardware
what happens in the Bell sampling case
well what we did is we just looked at
the recent paper of the region and
everyone else and looked at what happens
to this algorithm for the Bell sampling
this
we went through the proof and tried to
um
to get in get an upper bound on the
trace distance of the sampled Quantum
state in the algorithm
turns out the upper bound to the trace
distance that you get here is
exponentially large
so the algorithm seems to be very
specific to the choice of computational
basis as a measurement in particular if
you now do a bell sampling measurement
the best upper bound that we could yet
come up with is an exponentially large
upper Bound for the sample distribution
in this algorithm
and there might be reasons for that the
reason might be that if you look at the
Bell sampling distribution actually all
paulies contribute to the distribution
you can't only look at the Z poly say
which at the end of your
people who don't know about it
Just Not For a Moment
um
of the end of your path that you're
sampling have a z now you actually need
to take into account all paulies right
because we saw that the Bell sampling
distribution is basically an overlap
with poly matrices so you really have to
look at all the parties
so there might be it might be the case
that simulating Bell sampling in the
constant noise regime is actually
something that's more difficult than
computational basis
so is the Quantum advantage of cell
being more noise or buses
okay
that was it let me summarize
so I asked this question whether there's
a scalable verifiable in this key
pointing Advantage by looking at random
circuit sampling experiments and asking
whether you can make them verifiable a
little bit
um and I told you how in Bell sampling
you still have hardness of sampling but
then also you have a structured output
distribution which has efficient
property tests
and I came up with you know two
tentative uh conjectures one that if you
add those tests to the Cross entropy
benchmarking test then you might have a
more noise robust Quantum Advantage
um and then or more difficult to spoof
by classical algorithm content advantage
and then the other was that maybe the
Bell sampling distribution is
um maybe Bell sampling is actually more
noise robust to constant local noise in
the scalability in terms of the
scalability of the advantage then
standard basis
I ask you a lot of questions and I hope
that you know some of you
um might take the time to look at them
one was of course the noise robustness
of bell sampling the question of
hardness of achieving High test scores
on those various tests that I gave you
then there's the question which I
haven't raised yet but which I think is
very interesting is whether Bell
sampling is actually a universal model
of quantum computation
so you could think that we I don't know
it yet you could think that maybe now
you can encode qubits in the bases
rather than just computational basis
States for example
then there's the question well I said
there were tests but I haven't actually
written down exactly this is what you
should do so how do you actually make
the best possible use of the samples
that you get for from a bell sampling
experiment for different use cases say a
complexity theoretic test or an
experimental test
then one question that I think is very
interesting basically coming from this
um you know intuition that Bell sampling
is intermediate between four fall
tolerance and just single copy what
happens if you look at more copies
actually back in the 90s sometime that
when Paul tolerance was invented there
was a paper which looked at you know a
sort of repetition code for Quantum
Quantum systems which basically said
well you take many copies of a system
you project it onto the symmetric
Subspace that's going to mitigate some
errors
maybe that that sort of idea you can
also run here but now not for computing
expectation values on a single copy but
really for the samples from the
distribution
that's all thank you very much for your
attention
[Applause]
fact that
if you have a single copy of a column
stay and you wish to make a bunch of
measurements which will in advance give
you the outcome of the product of any
calories
it's exponentially better to have two
copies and make double measurements
right and that's shown by information by
just information Theory stuff yeah so is
your thing related to that anyway it's
reminiscent it's reminiscent yes it's
reminiscent but it's not the same
because I'm not sure if I know exactly
which work you're talking about but I
think what they do is maybe they do
random measurements in entanglement
annual copies
they just
I mean as far as I understand is you
want to make a certain number of
measurements and I'm going to tell you
afterwards I want you to tell me the
expected value of a product
uh in that state right and you can show
that forever
copies
but then you make gel measurements with
you know water end measurements you get
a set of numbers right which allows
that's exactly
make a bowel measurement you can compute
the outcome of any product of poly
measurement right yeah intensity and
then you just need well then you
estimate the trace roll P Squared
essentially and then you just make one
additional measurement to get the sign
of it
right right exactly that's exactly
that's exactly the sort of Advantage
right that you know now you're going
into the
mixtape picture sometimes right so
you're really looking at overlaps
between the statements okay
oh
um so you're like copy and pasting the
circuit and then doing
you could also Imagine doing other
the
inverse circuit or the complex conjugate
circuit yeah yeah
I mean if actually so for example for
this magic test and learning
zipper plus these circuits if you if
you're able to take the circuit and the
complex conjugate things will become
much easier much easier because you
don't yeah yeah
two copies there's a difference
yeah there's a big difference and I mean
I think this is really what's intrinsic
to Quantum Mechanics right the bells say
you'd have to start with two
okay yeah I just meant like I know what
you meant
if not let's uh we'll come back at two
thank you
foreign